der deutsche Lehrerverband warnt unsere
Schüler werden immer schwächer in Mathe
lesen und Naturwissenschaften die Folgen
sind verheerend wie diese Berliner
nachhilfegruppe beweist die seit Z
Jahren vergeblich versucht gemeinsam zu
regieren Christian schafft es einfach
nicht einen verfassungskonformen
Haushalt vorzulegen die Ursachen liegen
schon in der Grundschulzeit als
Grundschüler habe ich Mickey ma gelesen
und
Autobild bleiben aber katastrophal er
hier weiß nicht was eine Insolvenz ist
Karl wiederum scheitert an einer
einfachen krankenhausreform und Klara
wollte 400.000 Wohnungen im Jahr bauen
schafft im bererkunterricht aber nicht
mal ein Vogelhäuschen deshalb endlich
mehr Geld für Bildung